Mr Miliband I wonder if you would answer
a question for us on the Sky News selfie
stick there you are there's your first
selfie stick interview and but it's my
first selfie stick interview I'm very
proud to be doing at this guy move well
we wanted to know a little bit about
yourself yes we've done that yeah and so
what were you like when you were 18 what
were your interest what we up to I cared
a lot about the world I was actually
living in America for a time working the
media just before going to university er
I was actually an intern and uh and I
was sort very interested in what British
politics but also global it's used what
was happening in the world yeah what did
you do on a night out though what were
you interested what did i do in a night
out get the things that most teenagers
did I drank a bit too much you know
uh-huh but you know I feel I grew up in
a household where you know I said I said
in the Q&A you know you were taught to
care about the world and what's
happening in the world I had a great
times living in New York for ya with my
dad and I had actually great time okay
thanks doctor thank you thank you